don't
[Music]
um
the privilege
right
[Music]
is
okay
foreign
[Laughter]
what
foreign
hi everyone i'm scott feinberg from the
hollywood reporter thank you for joining
us i am here with juho
the director of the finnish oscar entry
compartment number six juho great to see
you where am i speaking to you from
or where are you
from i have roma helsinki oh
well the scene that we are focused on
today
um
is interesting for a number of reasons i
mean this movie as as folks know is
primarily set on a train but this is a
scene during a brief period when they
are off the train and i wonder if you
can talk about uh its significance in
the film and why it's the scene that you
selected it's kind of a specific scene
because it's uh
the way it was made it's actually
the only scene that is partly improvised
in this film
um
but it also
relates to this idea of authenticity
that we
tried so much to
achieve with this with this film
and and i think in this
scene we
we've got with what we wanted like
losing a little bit of the control and
letting things happen i think uh we
achieved more than we
lost
so in that sense it's kind of a
a good example of
our
way of filmmaking well and i think also
it seems to me maybe it's a turning
point in the story in the sense that
this woman and this man seemed to be
polar opposite she's coming out of this
relationship right where she sort of
thinks of herself as an intellectual and
he's certainly not and yet here she sees
him differently because she's with his
foster mother and seeing that he
actually does have a another side to him
right
yes yes this was the
i think the
main motive of
johardi the russian guy to take her
to take laura to this
place is to
not just to
introduce
this woman
but actually to show
the way this woman is seeing him
like because
i know maybe maybe she is the only one
who has
watched like
saw him mine in a good light
i think that he's a good man
yeah so this this gaze
is the
thing that that he wants to show
yeah
so that's what he's
that's the function of him in this scene
i wonder if we can talk about how she
uh perhaps is changed by the scene
because i know that you say
um you know a big part of this is her
discovery that she
maybe is more comfortable
not amongst intellectuals but amongst
common people and here we've got the
foster mother telling jokes about you
knows corny silly jokes about redheads
in china and
drinking moonshine and in some ways she
seems more comfortable here than she did
at the beginning of the film at this
party with intellectuals
yes yes because they
uh basically heard
the
personal joy journey of the protagonist
is from this uh
fancy moscovian apartment
uh
filled with
nice people
intellectuals something that he would
like to be but she is not and therefore
she is feeling this uh
like as an outsider all the time and
she's
she's hiding herself
and she's trying to be something she's
not which is really uncomfortable
uh
state of mind
and
and i think
when she goes to this trip
um
has to be share this compartment with
loja this uh
annoying
frozen guy who will like you said
doesn't feel like intellectual at all
it's actually like like
like she's almost like watching a mirror
and
slow slowly accepting that this is the
way i look this is who i am
and the petroglyphs are such an
interesting aspect of this because
i guess
you know
they represent
permanence and
uh
you know the history
and yet
the desire to see them that she is
always talking about is basically just
quoting what somebody else has said to
her and i wonder if you can just talk
about
about that aspect of things it's does
she even personally really
want to see these or is it just because
she's supposed to want to see them
yes
you're quite exactly right it's kind of
a stolen dream it's like it's mentioned
that it's actually irena's stream
to see this
and i i think her motive
to see these petroglyphs is actually
more
to be the person who could please irena
like okay yeah like when irena says like
i'm really interested of this petroclus
and when you are
in love or you would like to be loved
you are like
then yes actually i have the same
interest we are so similar and and this
is all
uh fake because she's so insecure i
think she's trying to
be loved as a person that she is not
which is
not a good
opposition to be
right she's not not being authentic uh
not being her authentic self i guess
let's go back to the very
beginning this film was inspired by a
novel by rosa lixum but it has changed
considerably with her blessing and i
wonder if you can talk about how you
first
came across the novel and why you think
it appealed to you i think there are
some
uh
perhaps parallels that you see in this
story
to filmmaking
when i
read this novel like 10 years ago i was
immediately very interested to
about it it was really inspiring because
it's
it's very cinematic book many scenes
that you can
feel you can
see strong visuals and
and
at the same time i was like really i
haven't done even my debut film yet so i
felt that okay at the same time i
realized this is impossible to do now
and and also it had like
multiple time layers and lots of
characters and all all that so
even though
i felt
this is inspiring film uh novel for uh
filmmaking i
i tried to abandon like yeah now i'm not
going to touch it
but when i when i met rosa like some
few years after i was i was still
thinking about this
novel
i asked her permit like
what do you think about this idea she
gave us all the
freedom to do whatever we want so i
think that was the moment when i really
started to believe that okay it is
possible
because when we have all freedom to do
what we want then well nothing is
impossible in a way
well this brings us to an important part
of this uh
challenge for you of making this film
which is that you actually with a small
crew and your two main actors
actually shot this on the train that
they are apparently
on as characters um talk about what a
challenge that is
you can decide whether the challenges
are interesting or boring ones
and i for me this kind of uh
locations like authentic locations and
which are not like totally
in your own control
i
for me as a director i i'm so much more
awake i'm so much i'm all the time
inspired and all these
challenges and obstacles that you're
having that just like
inspiring limitations or something like
that
and if you're working on a studio
you could create basically anything you
want you have all the possibilities
but
you have to put
a huge amount of your energy and focus
on this illusion
that you are creating
and
we couldn't afford this let
thing this this uh
new
new kind of studio
so
the other option was to shoot in a green
screen and i felt that
i'm not going to
do it i don't want the actors to look on
a green screen
if there's option that they could
actually watch out from a window seeing
the landscape passing by uh
i have to say in one point even though
this was like my
dream to do film like this and
at some point i was
recreating like
i told before the shootings i told you
uh in one interview that
filmmaking shouldn't be easy it means
that you don't
care what you are doing if you are just
trying to find the easiest way
and at some point i was thinking that
filmmaking shouldn't be this hard either
great
we started with these scenes and we were
all there with our film crew and i think
it really created a nice
team spirit as well
so we had like a crazy experience so it
was nice to
continue the shooting scene i would
guess that your two
closest collaborators on this were the
actors who play your main characters and
i wonder if
you knew them before this film if they
knew each other because
i mean this was obviously a
very close
collaboration and if they didn't work
out with each other or if or if you
didn't if you weren't sure that they
were
right for the part you could have had a
very bad experience here how did you all
find each other
uh well i
with sadie harlot and finnish actress we
we didn't know before but we
we had a
common friend who proposed that i should
meet her when i was
still trying to figure out this
character and i we were still writing
the scripts
and i felt like now i i need somebody
that
nothing
not necessarily the actress for this
part but somebody that i can really
start you know creating a real life
character in the end it was impossible
to think anybody else
right
but then we had the difficulties to find
the russian guy because also in our
script the guy was so much older
uh as it is in the novel
and
what i saw in carlo vibari film festival
i saw this film called the bull
uh it's a student film russian film uh
that was playing in
in east of west
competition i was there in missouri
and i really
liked his performance in the film
and
now i want to meet him and the casting
director told me that you know this is
the
totally opposite kind of a guy that
we've been searching for all the time
and he's
he's like half of the age than
your character in the script
yeah but i just you know i
want to meet him
anyway
and
i didn't even know why i was just like
yeah he's a good actress but so but in
russia are like a
huge amount of great actors
uh but
anyway we went to moscow to meet him
with sadie and we've already met
a lot of russian guys and this felt
immediately right
it was not just the way
he acted or she acted but it was the
combination the way they
felt together
and the only problem was that it was
not matching the guy from our script
but uh for me casting is such an
important
moment and
especially in this kind of film that
actually builds on this chemistry
between these two main characters so
i i was ready to change the guy from the
script to much better
with his eurovirus of a guy
right
and
yeah i think that was really defining
moment of the whole film it was also
before this
thing i always reached this idea that
it's about two different kind of
characters who are
trapped in this
same compartment but
i realized
when trying to figure out the reason why
i feel that your is the one why but this
couple is so good i realized that it's
not about to
opposite kind of a character it's
actually two exactly similar kind of
absolutely characters who are just like
in the beginning they are pretending to
be as
different and uh
yeah so it was
it was late
information for myself but i was so
happy
to really
find him i think that's really
really nailed to what the film is about
absolutely worked out beautifully and uh
congratulations best of luck the rest of
the way and thanks for thanks for doing
this
thank you thank you